The joe rogan experience.
Yeah,
that's it.
You know what?
As much as I'm afraid I'm going to make
that walk that they have the day of the
day,
the day of it,
and I'm going to do it regardless.
It sounds more crazy.
I would be more afraid of a guy that says,
I'm like,
it says like I'm afraid,
but you know what I'm going to still
do with and I don't care if I'm afraid
bring it,
I'll do it.
Like this is sound crazy to me.
More than a guy said,
oh no,
no,
no.
I'm not afraid because this guy,
he's a light.
He's afraid to say that he's afraid.
He's like man,
you know what I mean?
To me personally,
that's where it is.
Yeah.
The posturing and posing.
It's unnecessary.
Exactly.
But you are afraid of aliens though,
right?
Yeah.
My friend has
a path mapped out in your house.
How to get out of the aliens show up.
No,
that's the rumor man.
That's what I heard.
I heard you have a plan cause I know
you like to use game plans so I know,
I know cat ready and I know Jujitsu.
So the alien show up.
I put a triangle choke on him and I
also have a cat ammo so I kept that to a
Japanese.
Get that now.
So either they come,
I can slice them apart.
Wow.
Do you keep a sword in your house?
It's a collection.
You know it's funny.
It's have to not bring
any crazy bitches home.
I man sword and crazy bitches.
I have this tax on the side of my bed
that I always forget is there and I was
like almost cut my
finger off all the time.
And you should put down in the garage
big sword slash meat
cleaver that it's just
so do you really have a fear of aliens
or is this just a bullshit rumor?
Cause it,
what didn't you do a countdown show and
you did a whole thing talking about how
you being scared of
being abducted by aliens.
Yeah,
I'm scared.
I'm scared of a lot of things
I'll get,
I'll get into it.
Like I can,
I got,
I kept talking about it right now or the,
and I'm talking about it right now.
It's one day we're going to come all
that and make a big thing about it.
But no,
wait,
hold on,
hold on.
Yeah.
Have you had an experience with aliens?
No.
No,
no,
no.
I don't believe you.
Okay.
No,
I don't know.
You don't know.
You might have had an experience with it.
I,
my manager going to have
a heart attack right now.
My brother,
I would never do or
lead you down any path.
It's bad for your career.
Just as you said that it's
good that to be afraid.
It's also good to be
honest about everything.
Even shit.
That sounds crazy and I love it.
That's the thing.
I'm honest.
I like,
look,
I'm on s I'm afraid,
but I don't want to have
to tell everything on,
on the phone.
It's true.
You don't,
but,
but you know,
you have sex with an alien
because you're a smart guy.
Let me tell you,
you're a very smart guy.
You know,
you know how to dig,
dig into people's mind.
And as Martin,
I like you ally.
I hate that about you because
he put me on the spot right now.
But he's a very smart guy.
But now I know I gotta I gotta go to the,
listen,
if I was on an alien spacecraft
and I had sex with an alien,
like I'm assuming you did,
I feel like I would just
come out and talk about it.
I don't know why he would hold that back.
No,
but I mean,
ah,
something happened George.
I don't know.
It's either,
it's either I'm crazy or,
or,
uh,
maybe it really happened,
but I,
I hope that I'm crazy.
I don't think you're crazy.
I hope I,
that could be pre crazy cause he know
some people like some great mine and you
know,
they had,
they had been hallucinating
stuff or some people are,
I'll do say manioc with depressive.
Some people are,
are uh,
OCD,
some people are dead,
some people are dead
and they're still great.
They've been able to achieve
great stuff on their life,
you know,
so maybe I'm crazy when I was,
I don't know.
Um,
I opened these experiences.
I can help you one way or these
experiences happening at night.
I am not sure.
I have not.
I'm not sure I have any of
these experiences happen
while you've been in the
dream state or were you just been dreaming
or just asleep and you were woken up?
I am not sure that that expert,
I don't know.
I don't remember anything that was the,
was it nighttime type things?
It was at nighttime when you think you
might have had something happened to,
uh,
I can't say something happened to me.
I have no proof.
I just don't know.
What I'm going to tell you about is your
brain produces a chemical while you're
sleeping.
But I'm gonna,
I'm gonna tell you something and
I'm going to be honest about it.
Sometime
I'm looking at the clock and it's like
I wake up and I look at the clock or
right after and it's like the clock had
events like a four hour or two hours.
There was a time zone that I
don't remember what happened.
It's called falling asleep.
I hope so.
What do you think you think you're
getting snatched up and taken away for a
couple of hours?
No.
Think I'm,
maybe I fall asleep.
That's why I hope that's
why I hope or I can drive.
I can drive my car,
I can drive my car.
And it already happened.
I drove,
I drove my car.
[inaudible] I dunno,
I drove my car in a normal day,
like going somewhere.
Then I look and there's two hour pass.
I'm like two hour.
I'd just pass like this.
Like maybe,
maybe I didn't see it.
Maybe I didn't,
I didn't,
I maybe I watched their
tie the wrong time.
Like I watched my clock and
I made a mistake myself.
Right.
Most likely,
right?
Yes,
of course.
I hope so.
Well that's very minor stuff.
That's very minor stuff.
Yeah.
Um,
but that could be,
you talked being tired because
you push yourself and less stress.
It's exactly,
that's exactly what I hope.
So.
It's exactly what I hoped.
So,
but you don't have any memories of great
dudes putting fingers up your butt.
No,
I don't.
None of that.
I've had a job where you're
driving down the street,
like on the highway and you're just
like kind of dazed out and you're like,
wait,
how long I've been,
I've,
I've been dazed out for like 20 minutes.
What have I been doing for 20 minutes?
Autopilot.
Yeah.
And then like,
you just realize like
almost all of a your home.
Yeah.
But,
um,
did the thing about being
exhausted and sleep,
uh,
you know,
and having these experiences at night,
the,
there's a,
a chemical your brain makes that's,
uh,
one of the most powerful
psychedelic drugs don't demand.
So one of the things
they're trying to connect,
it's called DMT.
And one of the things
they're trying to connect is,
um,
people having near death experiences
and people that have had UFO alien
abduction type experiences and this
chemical and that they can introduce this
chemical into the human body.
And these people have very
similar experiences to what
they had when they had a
Ufo encounter or when they had,
you know,
a white light near death
experience and counter.
And it's most likely there's
this chemical that's doing this.
So when people having these experiences
that are very realistic and they do
believe they're being taken the board by,
you know,
a Ufo somewhere,
they might not be wrong,
but this is not a Ufo encounter.
This is just firefighting object.
The,
I ain't gone through,
we talk about that.
If they had been thinking a board,
this is,
this is different.
It's like,
hey,
it could be a third type and encounter.
There's many ways,
but this is different.
Yeah.
But I,
the I,
you talk about me,
I don't have any,
I don't have any memory of such thing,
but I thing I'd,
I though like I have,
like you say,
sometimes I fall,
I fall asleep,
then I wake up is the
time passed and I'm like,
well it's like I just,
cause you're tired man.
That's not aliens.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Are you worried?
He like,
man,
maybe it's an alien.
It's kind of what you do.
No,
it's because I am,
I felt like I didn't fall,
I didn't fall asleep and I'm not tired.
I'm wide awake,
awake,
but I fall asleep like
this and it's kind of,
I mean it's kind of weird.
Hard sparring days.
No,
no.
Just a normal day and I get good
happen everyday when you get a Gopro,
like a camera and just record
yourself all the time that happens.
Watch it.
I mean there's things record
for like eight hours at a time.
Some of them.
Yeah.
How long has this been going on?
Since I'm a kid.
Wow.
Wouldn't it be crazy if the aliens like
manufactured you to be a mixed martial
arts fighter to like,
let's see if we could just turn this
[inaudible] would have happened.
I would have been much better than,
than,
than this.
Much better than this.
You're the fucking champion.
But if I would be out of
you in the manufacturer,
I would it be a super amount of,
you know,
well they just don't want
to get ridiculous with it.
It would be.
Yeah,
that would be,
obviously you can't turn a
guy into a goddamn superhero.
I don't know.
Maybe that manufacturer
Jon Jones,
maybe they did.
Aldo.
Maybe someone needs to talk to
them about their sleep patterns.
Maybe they're falling asleep behind the
wheel too and being sucked to board a
space ship for repairs.
Maybe they don't want to talk about it.
Maybe they don't say it,
but maybe they are.
I don't know.
I don't have enough breadth in the,
I think it's funny though that
that's maybe one subject that you,
uh,
you had a really hard time talking
about that I do because it's,
it's,
it sounds crazy and I,
and I will talk about it one day.
I'm going to talk about my,
my,
all that stuff and uh,
but no,
no,
I don't get the even through this.
Yeah.
Maybe I probably asked one day,
I'll go,
I'll,
I'll talk about stuff.
But it's not what you promised one day.
I promise.
One day.
What is the difference?
No tomorrow.
Did you see rocky three when Apollo
creed says that the rocky Balboa,
you said maybe,
maybe I will die one day,
maybe I'll die it tomorrow.
I hope I touched wasn't
nothing that people,
oh.
And I'm like,
how did you say that it was that French?
I'll touch wood,
not I touched the there would make
it happen,
you know?
Yeah.
Just let it go.
Just whatever information you've got,
spill it.
No,
but I don't know.
I'm doing my,
I'm doing my own research.
I'm researching on myself.
Like you say,
that's the thing that you just told me.
It's very interesting the chemical that,
but anyway,
that's probably that.
I'm happy that I meet through today.
And you tell that about me
because I make me make me happy.
No.
Well I think a lot of people think
they're going crazy and it's not.
It's just your brain makes
psychedelic drugs is true.
Your brain produces it and parts
of your liver and your lungs,
they don't know why this
stuff is in the body,
but it's,
it's a super potent psychedelic.
You brain makes it,
it happens when you're sleeping.
So if like the speculation is
that it happens during rem sleep,
I don't think they have the most
accurate way of measuring it,
but they know it's in the body
and they believe it's the,
the theory is that it comes out during
periods of heavy stress or when your body
thinks it's going to die or in rem sleep
and that those are the Times that you
have higher levels of this stuff
in your neurochemical soup.
That's an interesting,
crazy,
why would you brain,
why would your brain produce an
incredibly potent psychedelic drug?
So a lot of people that are having
these nighttime experiences,
it could be just varying levels of this
chemical that's going around in your
brain,
but that doesn't mean that
these experiences aren't real.
We don't know what the
fuck sleeping is anyway.
I mean,
what is sleeping?
You shut your eyes,
you shut off,
you don't exist in this plane and your
consciousness goes somewhere else.
Like literally you have no memory of a
giant chunk of your day and we have no
problem with it.
And yet we don't connect it to any other
realm or the idea of there being other
dimensions.
You go into another dimension
when you go to sleep,
okay,
you do,
you just shut off,
you stop and for all intents and purposes,
you are in another dimension and if
while you're in that other dimension,
your brain is being pumped
with this psychedelic chemical
that when you take it,
when you're sober makes you have
these incredible experiences.
It only seems to,
it just seems like a
normal thing to look into,
like people that you should be
looking into that like what?
What is what is happening
when you're sleeping,
your sleep,
you go away and everybody's
just so used to it.
They're like,
no big deal.
We just go away.
Just go away for eight hours a day.
You know,
everybody's scared to die and
no one's scared to fall asleep.
You're,
you're just,
you're shutting off man.
You know you're going to be
back so you're not worried,
but you're shutting off.
Whatever that is,
you know,
is just accepted.
If sleeping didn't exist,
it would be the craziest fucking thing.
If all of a sudden you told people that
they had to shut off for eight hours a
night and just completely not be,
they'd be like,
what are you talking about?
I've got to shut off the bike.
Yeah,
you're going to shut off for eight hours
a night and you're not going to know
what's happening.
People can touch your balls
while you're sleeping.
You'll have no way of stopping them.
There's a lot of things that can happen
that that showed us,
like you said,
we don't know.
We don't know.
We don't know what the fuck that is.
I could,
I could like,
you know what I can say?
It's not that I'm afraid to be crazy.
It's just I,
I can say whatever dad,
I won't and we don't know.
Maybe.
You know what I mean?
We don't know.
We don't know the truth.
We'd have no idea.
Yeah.
Somebody might be stealing time from you.
They might be stealing time.
They're like,
this motherfucker's got it.
I,
the truth is I feel like ad experience,
but I don't know what it is.
So for me to say it salient or say it's
a dead drug chemical you're talking
about?
I don't know.
I can't,
I can't tell you right now.
I don't know what it is,
but I did.
I felt like it could have
been an experience or not.
Maybe I felt maybe I'm crazy and it's a
normal thing that everybody would like.
Maybe I,
but right now I,
uh,
like,
I don't know.
It's too,
I'm making my own research
too to find out about that.
How are you researching?
When I research a lot of stuff,
uh,
they commit that reason things
and go on the Internet now.
It's another thing that
he just said to me.
I'm going to research that
made by research on their own.
I mean by resources,
things that the people that have,
I've tried because that lap laptops
time that you don't remember,
they've been,
some people been hypnotized
and they are the bad,
the bad,
the,
you know what I mean?
That venture,
and I don't want to be an uptight,
well that's very controversial.
You know,
what's happening during hypnosis,
hypnotic regression.
It's very controversial because there's
a lot of people that believe that you
can introduce fake memories and to a
person while they're unconscious and then
you could,
you know,
you,
you could steer the events in one way
or another and introduce false memories.
It's not,
it's not very,
it's not very reliable.
I don't think so.
That's one of the big things about these
people that have these crazy stories
from hypnotic regression.
Like what the fuck is really going on?
You know,
you don't know.
A lot of times people that are in therapy
in the first place or a little wound
does.
So it's that those are the
types of people that you're,
you're dealing with.
You're hypnotizing them.
And then you're finding out about
these nutty experiences with aliens.
Who knows what the fuck.
So credit,
he's just to say,
you think a fish in the water.
Okay.
And that fisheries it eve is,
and then as that environment,
let's say a fisherman,
he grabbed my fish in the water,
it pulls it off the water,
look at him,
look at,
make the fish,
look around and dropped
the fish back in the water.
The fish after is going to go back to
his friend and he's going to tell did the
other fish at him,
man,
I build poured out of the water.
In an end it was the people were
breeding air was another environment.
I saw a human being pulled
know like amen grabbing me.
I saw trees,
I saw a bird in the sky.
I saw,
I liked like I saw and I'm like,
I see a different thing in different
and then you put it back yard official
think he's completely insane,
you know?
So maybe in a way we're all like fish and,
and maybe there is something
like you said that when you see,
but another university or another well
or something and we don't know and we're
right next to it,
but we don't know.
And if that's what I'm doing,
research,
I want to see,
you know,
I,
when I grow as a human being,
fine,
what was the truth?
Even though I probably will never found
out the truth and I want to get closer,
closer and find my own research
to see what's happening,
you know,
and we're all in the same pattern,
you know?
[inaudible]
you ready to record recording?
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?